in episode four of what if we see
something we haven't seen in the series
thus far the story revolves around dr
stephen strange and his love interest dr
christine palmer from the get-go it's
obvious the world is different than the
one we know from the mcu as stephen is
head over heels in love with christine
in doctor strange it's evident there are
feelings between the two but steven's
ego and narcissism often prevent their
love from blossoming in episode 4 the
duo appears to have genuine passion
between them which isn't hindered by his
cockiness the episode begins with a duo
taking a ride in steven's car after some
chit chat it looks like they're about to
be in a terrible car crash but steven is
able to maneuver his sports car so they
avoid the accident unfortunately they're
hit by another vehicle from behind
which sends them spiraling off the road
the accident is reminiscent of stevens
from the characters live-action film the
difference is this time he's not alone
christine dies in the crash and the
watcher tells us how this universe is
different from the one we know
in this universe steven strange didn't
lose his hands
but his heart
just like in doctor strange stephen
still travels to the comatose where he
learns about the mystic arts as he seeks
answers to help deal with his grief he
experiments with the eye of agamotto as
he learns time travel as possible but is
warned by wong not to tinker with it
tinkering with time can weaken the very
fabric of the universe the episode
speeds over the death of the ancient one
and stephen's defeat of dormammu as he
becomes a sorcerer supreme it also
leaves out baron mordo entirely a
character essential to the plot in the
doctor strange film while these events
fall in line with the ones we've seen in
the mcu what happens next as a complete
left turn from what we know steven is
still unable to deal with the loss of
christine two years after her death he
used zaya vagamoto to travel back to the
night of their car accident and
maneuvers his vehicle differently to
avoid the same crash while he's
successful they're still hit by another
car in an entirely different accident
and land in the same spot resulting in
christine's death yet again stephen
continues to turn back time over and
over drastically changing the events of
the evening to prevent tragedy but no
matter what he does christine dies every
single time
it's here we learn from the ancient one
that christine's death is an absolute
point in time she explains that without
the death of his loved one he would
never have mastered the mystic arts or
defeated dormammu suggesting her death
is necessary to save the universe
stephen won't accept this and goes down
a dangerous path of attempting to
reverse his absolute point in time he
seeks answers at the lost library of
cagliostro steven learns at the library
that he can obtain the power to reverse
an absolute point by gaining the power
of other beings through absorption his
dark path takes an even darker turn as
he summons mythical beings just so he
can absorb their powers steven becomes
incredibly strong even prompting the
watcher to consider intervening soon we
cut back to an earlier point in the
episode just after doctor strange
defeats dumamu the moment just before
stephen reverts time he puts off his
time travel and when he goes outside he
sees his reality slowly starting to
wither away as buildings and people
appear to disintegrate the ancient one
shows up again and we learn of a new
twist
it turns out the ancient one split
reality into two timelines the moment
stephen used the eye of agamotto to
travel back in time using dark magic
this allowed two stevens to
simultaneously exist in one universe and
shortly after learning this the doctor
strangers come face to face one fights
for the sake of the universe and the
other fights to save christine by
reversing that absolute point in time
it's a brutal battle between the two
with dark steven coming out victorious
as he absorbs the power of his
counterparts he is successful in
stopping christine's death that night
but that choice ends up decimating the
entire universe steven learns too late
that reversing christine's death changes
everything and in this new reality
everything crumbles and he loses his
love yet again steven talks to the
watcher as a universe disintegrates and
admits he's always felt his presence in
a last-ditch effort he begs him to
intervene and to set things right
you
you can stop this
please
fix this but the watcher refuses saying
that interfering with time and events
only leads to further destruction so he
watches the world crumble as stephen and
christine perish
as we learned in the three episodes
prior one decision can change absolutely
everything in episode 4 it's more
evident than ever as the watcher
explains that these choices can destroy
the entire universe clearly some choices
bear more weight than others steven's
response to losing the use of his hands
in dr strange was substantially
different from the reaction he had to
the death of christine both stories saw
him try him for gangstor mamu and become
the sorcerer supreme but his partner's
death was too much for him to bear which
led to all-out destruction through his
always evident arrogance while the
difference in this story was christine's
death over the destruction of his hands
it was ultimately stephen's decision to
reverse that absolute point in time
which ended the universe we're still
left wondering will the watcher ever
intervene this is the most we've seen
him interact with the story thus far but
if he wouldn't intervene as the universe
was being destroyed what situation might
we see that would force him to step in
and do something
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]